aunque con menos intensidad los
enfrentamientos en la frontera entre la
franja de gaza e Israel continúan este
viernes los residentes de los
territorios palestinos inspeccionaron
los daños causados por el último ataque
de Benjamin netanyahu el Ministerio de
vivienda y Obras Públicas de gasa
reportó 47 casas dañadas y 19 destruidas
el hogar de uno de los afectados
me sorprendió que los vecinos salieran y
gritarán que iban a atacar la casa
nosotros no teníamos conocimiento de eso
y nadie nos dijo y cuando vimos gente
corriendo salimos como estábamos esta
misma jornada los gasaties enterraron a
más de sus muertos
por su parte en Israel las alarmas
antiaéreas sonaron una vez más y la
cúpula de hierro entró en acción ante
los cohetes provenientes de la franja
eran al menos las seis de la tarde
estaba acostado en la cama y vagamente
podía escuchar el sonido de la alarma al
principio en realidad pensé que era de
ciudades cercanas como quizás nésciona o
Sheen estaba medio despierto y después
de lo que pareció un minuto escuché una
explosión y el suelo tembló un poco los
misiles dejaron Al menos una casa
destruida La ola de ataques comenzó el
martes cuando las fuerzas de seguridad
de Israel la arremetieron contra varios
de los líderes de la yihadi islámica
bajo el pretexto de prevenir una acción
contra la nación hebrea